what's happened so far Stefano cannoli
completed Nefertiti's costume just in
time and creative director month with
Thierry Mugler scrutinized every tiny
detail it's the day of the dress
rehearsal today the whole show will be
performed straight through absolutely
everything should be perfect even the
makeup
it takes up to 40 minutes for Nina
mcCargo Nova to be made up as Nefertiti
for the principal dancer it's also a way
to mentally prepare costume on my scooty
costume and makeup they certainly make
it easier to slip into the role
lifestyle I insisted from them in the
auditorium costume designer Stefano
cannoli anxiously awaits the run-through
together with around 60 colleagues
who've been involved with the show
behind the scenes
the orchestra prepares for its cue the
16-person show band will be accompanying
the dress rehearsal live next to and
also behind the stage
in the meantime Nina McKagan OVA has
been transformed into Nefertiti
the dress rehearsal can begin
the show depicts Berlin's wild city life
which even the resurrected ancient
Egyptian Queen Nefertiti can't resist
supera right at this point you come
together
damn it and when the music ends you come
down but some scenes don't go quite to
plan
the run-through is interrupted after the
first act
it's why would a spoke it was good it
was good to see the whole show for the
first time or at least to see how
everything fits together these ISM
applause as father it was really
exciting but honestly we're not quite
there yet my dream hasn't quite been
realized my enormous love me here food
in the meantime Stefano cannoli occupies
himself with a few costume repairs it's
only after seeing the costumes on stage
that some of the weak spots become
apparent but he can no longer make any
fundamental changes a custom once it's
done one is that on the artist Denise
takes his own life and I can do anything
more than just stare at it and admire it
or regret him but I don't think so this
time is not the case
this is one of the key scenes in the
show as Nefertiti Nita Munk ago Nova
dances and then is carried off on a BMX
bike but even that doesn't go as planned
it's frustrating when such mistakes
happen so close to the opening night
Alexandra your Java goes over the scene
again with the dancers
almost every single step has reviewed
one more time in chief begun a lot of
things went wrong I'm not satisfied it
could have gone better apart if the
costume was missing I almost lost my
point shoe to move on the bicycle didn't
work but then they do say that if the
dress rehearsals lousy the opening night
will be fantastic no after this you put
the mirrors up on